all right so this is Stephens lion again
just so much to say about the suit if
you encounter a cotton candy lion don't
bring it home it probably just wants a
jewel in a pillow
yeah but will most likely stay with you
at least I'm assuming I see that lion on
everything cuz I'm a silly DS am a
character now um does yellow just lie it
they let him keep him just like amethyst
too but Wow what's it only amethyst case
that was very big oh yeah Dan is broke
oh I can't miss them bitch HOSA
whoa she's not always an Isis either but
um but yeah so he has a lion now I
pretty much comes across this light in
this sand world where they get this
jewel and he's pretty much average eye
shadows again he's pretty much
advertising him like oh you're the
softest thing in the world you're like
the cotton candy of the jungle Kingdom
I'm like you know mate over now for 2995
it did look like a giant plushy yeah I
mean it's like well done creatives well
done I was gonna always talk about how
the 80s was nothing like but just trying
to sell toys is like a more blatant you
could probably get this um but uh yeah
he has a cool roar I'm assuming it's a
he uh that can break down like that's
more of an it yeah probably
um and yeah and Steven thinks he has a
connection with it but really just why
the jewel Oh Stevens pregnant that was
really funny
ah what the hell is that onion thing
it's just like onion what about you and
it just it's like oh it's like I just
don't know what that was so there's some
kind of onion person that's either a
person or a mascot or I have no idea it
was just a mascot for the restaurant I
don't know - a comments don't explain it
I got a feeling we're gonna see that
blog guy later cuz why would he explain
his blog you know um just a joke didn't
go anywhere so even though it was kind
of funny oh my god
first of all uh so no that was very
funny uh you know the what I find
interesting about the show is that its
color scheme like during that sandstorm
as in myself you know if you told me you
would find like the colors brown and
peach and yellow
don't forget right yeah pink if you
would find all those interesting like
what but they they do good job I'm going
to say they look on it's just they they
make those colors appealing I would say
it straight up and friends I know me
well and my wife in particular know this
I hate those colors yeah those colors um
it somehow works in the show yeah you
know I don't know why I just yeah
golfing it in the in the colors any form
of pastels are probably my least
favorite colors on the planet the whole
seventies color palette scheme
altogether those those earth tones and
Browns and light oranges and puke greens
and yeah I always think I if though is
to so yeah I I don't know I there's
something about the show that where they
do it in an interesting way and I'm it
reminds me we were talking about I I got
him into Bob's Burgers and he said you
know you King came back yesterday and
he's like you were like there's the show
is not haha funny but there's something
mesmerizing mesmerizing about it yeah
something hypnotic and I I turned it I
turned to Doug today and I'm like you
know there's something about Steven
universe it's not thrilling but there's
something mesmerizing and hypnotic about
it like every time it's on I I kind of
just zone out I'm just like oh I
actually felt but I'm like there's
something very zen about it that I
really enjoy yeah what I watch it I it
sounds weird or maybe not I don't know
but it does kind of feel like I'm eight
years old watching a Saturday morning
cartoon kind of thing but not your
finest hour the best one or the most
riveting or anything like that but it's
he just sort of sucks you anywhere you
know it reminds you of those very
surreal 80s cartoons yeah um like on the
periphery of iU cities a gold baby
yeah even even even stuff like
Silverhawks and Thundercats uh or or
masters in the universe we're just weird
to watch like if you if you watch some
kind of objectively it like it really
hits you occasionally how weird they are
and it's just like here's a really weird
setting with weird-looking people here's
here's a muscle-bound man in a pink vest
with a blonde mop top running around
fighting a skeleton and the wear man and
he's got a green tiger it's like this
setting you start thinking about your
fuck um but and it's the same thing with
this show the second you start thinking
but you're like what the fuck but if you
just like let yourself go and just be
hypnotized by it it's kind of like whoa
yeah it's like the first time in a while
I think I watched the show a show I mean
it's a good way I was kind of like oh my
god wasn't like I don't yeah I was like
what's gonna happen I don't know I don't
get that way with Adventure Time I don't
get that way with grab you toys I get it
with this show yeah I talked to like fun
shows more but like I'm also watching
something like I had a friend who just
got me into like Phineas and Ferb and
they're they're very loud and an
adventure time they're they're very
in-your-face and a lot of fun but this
one it's just like it's like meditating
or something you yea lost in it like
just gonna catch your own thing we it's
almost like playing a video good at like
Super Mario Brothers or something and
you don't even think about it and you
realize that 20 minutes like 20 minutes
is past you're like where'd the time go
like you were just playing and just lost
and playing and it's kind of like that
it's a whole show so it has this feel
like it's doing its own thing but it's
not showing it off you know like even
though I love ya Adventure
and gravity falls and stuff I mean it's
really showing off how much of their own
thing they're doing them fine right
dumbbell another swing those are all
bright like adventure time in particular
bright primary colors very simple and
then gravity falls it's still very
shadowy but still strong I marry a color
based yeah very saturated colors in this
one it's like pearl in particulars
almost a D saturated characters this is
they're very light colors I was
commenting to you that she almost feels
penciled in like if the other characters
have very strong defined lines and she
feels like she's just been sketched in
barely painted with watercolors and
lichen and the background said that same
vibe to it so yeah if I the atmosphere I
see we were able to talk about this the
atmosphere that I get from it is that
most shows and it arguably
understandably shut understand police
are like hey come watch us you know
we're fun we're cool whatever
Steve universe has a feeling of you know
we're just gonna do our own thing you
are more than welcome to join us we
would love to have you but you know
we're gonna do our own thing no matter
what you know and if they're sort of
sleeping nature that you kind of respect
going in where all these other shows
like - no problem at all I really like
them for it are our very extreme and how
we're gonna do our own thing you doing
it amazing it's like grabbing gravity or
knowledge gravity falls is like mr.
whoosh upper but it's like the gremlin
shop like it's all weird shit you know
like home what's as an adventure time is
like the dancing monkey it's like the
dancing performers on the street blowing
shit up and like look at this it's like
a big magic show and this show is like
that weird guy just playing the guitar
in the corner the sad Spanish guitar
like hey hmm
but he doesn't even have like a like but
I'm offering up was no cup no nothing
and you just walk past him and stare at
him for a while he's them he is the me
this show is literally the music in the
background in an atmospheric see yeah
that's what the show is and it works it
just lulls you into the hypnosis yeah so
it's uh I mean when we say that I think
we're now talking about in a bad way oh
no it's actually a good way because
that's spearing hard to do
yeah it's if I get it is so strange and
it it I mean I in some ways as much as I
love adventure time and gravity falls
like their setups have it kind of easy
where it's like if they know if they're
just I mean what else what if they know
what they're doing right it's it's it's
bright colors you got mystery you got
all these things that can you know just
be like hey look at this this one it's
like it's a little harder come up with
something that just sucks you in without
having to you know do anything all that
fancy hmm I mean we've had one or two
episodes we've gone like really extreme
with something like that the fry guy and
stuff like that and I know there's other
ones oh yeah there's there's
occasionally but like we've had two
episodes in a row now where it's like
what the hell do you say yeah I I don't
know what to say there was a pink lion
it's if you describe it it's it's like
some I know it's like some haiku or
something there was a pink line a gem
and a pillow the lion is his friend that
like the end that's not a haiku but you
know it's like something like that it's
this is like it's almost never haiku to
have the end yeah all the souls are
right at it but it's got that feeling to
it it's like this is just like one giant
Zen haiku or no it's like you know it's
like a said Cohen yes like there is a
pink liar he wants the gem in the pillow
you do not want to give him the gem of
the pillow what do you do and what is
the sound of one hand clapping uh so no
it it was a good episode yeah you're
right we did a team m4 to talk about
them you know one again that that does
that is a testament to its artistry and
it's uh our desperation
well the no servant dog that I it's
different way of storytelling to UM
which I really respect so this is this
is closer to uh how I know what it
reminds me of no I got it or I should
say since Steven universe is probably
out first over the garden wall yeah sort
of thing it's like well does it say
pizza what the hell I mean I texted but
people that came from adventure time
it's our brain stuff and did their own
thing yeah so it's got that vibe to it
of like I don't know what the fuck you
say about this but it's fascinating to
watch yeah and this you know as much as
we always talk about hey it's nice when
we see something based on something else
do something kind of differently oh we
just talked about ant-man and stuff it
is nice to see something different do
something different you know just
something totally new come along and say
hey let's kind of do our own weird new
thing and see it become a big hit I
think we're seeing that much more TV
than we are in movies but um not to say
I'm against movies right now either but
uh yeah so no I am with you I think
there's a very cool environment and
atmosphere to it that's just kind of it
pulls you in in its own way and it
doesn't feel it needs to play by any
other right even the names you know I'm
like let's amethyst is that it I'm
offense and and guy is this so difficult
no no no but I'm saying like this no no
no I know I got it but from a marketing
standpoint
nobody would ever give those names I
mean look those are not these ease needs
to remember as if Colonel is so dead
Pearl's easy obviously and even Stevie
and even up I mean going in and not
explaining the show or how it works or
anything just starting right in the
middle I mean from a marketing
standpoint these are all not typically
good choices but that's part of its
charm that's part of why it works and I
think that's part of why it sucks so
many kids and adults in as well um so no
good so place up some price we talked
bass but SH it's what you did so you're
welcome you're welcome so I'll give you
a cookie if you shout oh so no they
don't know the reference they think
we've gone insane okay so I had a great
thing on Tom why just shows a shot from
the devil episode of like me Santa
Christ the devil and Rita for power
inches this is anyone that does not
watch a nostalgia critic explain this
picture so we have to Chris deputy
Reynolds and God but but again you could
with this
can the same thing like if you do watch
the show it's like explain what's going
on it's like it's tricky but fire the
Charmin - so um yeah that is amidst our
writing even I think haikus based on -
yeah I think I was still writing haikus
based on Steven universe this sounds
like fun this is because you would
totally confuse them for Zen haikus yeah
you would like now supposed to clear
your mind
oh it's also part of this large
complicated story that's almost the
exact opposite of Zen hikers but
nevertheless it could also be this two
sets of idols show a desert lion now
we'll need seven syllables oh it's gonna
take a while but you know that would
have fun with it
uh so that's it we'll see the next one
later